good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday woohoo
it's almost Friday almost and that means
it's almost merged and we're celebrating
a day early we are wearing our new merch
no this was not planned but this is like
my runaway favorite sweatshirt from the
drop so I was so excited to wear it and
we - what size to be wearing for people
who want to you're wearing it oversized
for fully address it covers my duty and
it's a size large this is also a size
large and it fits quite differently and
if I wanted to I had to wear shorts
underneath I think I'm gonna get in
Excel - awareness did you wear it as a
dress because I could use like a little
bit more lengthen like a little bit more
give and the tits this is like if I just
want aware it with leggings like I'm
just such a cool girl common again like
a chai latte if you know the cutest
sweatshirt ever it comes in one other
color in like a pink and but I'm loving
the teal by the way I thought the pink
was gonna be like the bestseller but I'm
thinkin the teal yeah chilly vibes we
have so much pain I by Jackie I couldn't
have said it better mr. Levi
oh yeah the aesthetic someone was saying
I didn't even realize it's like so
OnPoint
we took our standard pink and green I
mean like we tuned it up a little bit to
more like artisanal colored shades and I
feel as though the whole brand is gonna
benefit yeah the whole drop is sick we
did alive yesterday Claudia's brilliant
idea yes I had a really you know in this
business and I mean our business I don't
really come up with that many good ideas
like anything good we ever do it's
pretty much attributed she Jackie then
I'll call Jackie be like have an idea
and she's like no that's terrible and
like I know when to back down I said
Jackie let's do live and she was like no
I'm like but I you juggling Hilson
because I thought it was a good idea and
I know that they're far and few between
but I thought it was a good idea and
guess what ladies it happened don't give
up on your dreams you too can have good
ideas YouTube can don't back down from
your boss when they tell you you have a
bad idea yeah [ __ ] your boss but then
the boss also said I know it's important
to you to see your idea through so we
will do it and it was great we just like
a little face time live I've never done
that before and we showed some of our
favorite products everybody showed all
the products we were like we make three
of each but also we didn't even have all
the products like we don't even have all
the notebooks that's sure we're missing
from our collections like two pen
pencils but I'm glad because I want to
order stuff because it's so much fun to
get your morning toast merch in the mail
and there's all
some things that you haven't seen yet
some bestsellers coming back it will all
be available at chat morning toast calm
when this show ends tomorrow so gird
your loins it's it's gonna be fabulous
in the new favorite word of counselor
Smith it's going to be realized
fabulous okay he's fabulous look at look
at counselor snitches spider unfabulous
oh can I see something about that
sweatshirt because I got it too and I
thought for sure like I wasn't gonna
need a cropped sweater I'm not much I
could crop top gal given like my
oversight spewpa but I got that
sweatshirt in large in both colors and
it is my absolute favorite thing it's
longer than you would expect so your
soup is pretty much covered and I pair
it with like a cute white tee and
anything for like you know in Urban
Outfitters kind of vibe and it looked
really good yeah we're very super
friendly brand here of course and you're
in good hands so also the sizing for
those asking was extra small to 3x right
yes I believe so
so hopefully everyone can get what they
want we told you guys it's not unlimited
stock this time because we're planning
on keeping the store open forever but
there's Johnny we we ordered we're
playin big inventory fees over at our
warehouse you should be able to get what
you want yeah but if you want to get
your exact size sign on smell amazing
you know sign on early smells a fabulous
that is my simple request once that it
looks bigger and better and better pay
would love this collection this by the
way this should be the shar-pei
collection no we should do a shar-pei
collection because that opens up a world
of possibilities and Inventure it's
fabulous events yeah even needs like you
know like Pinkberry pens with like
little pom-poms on the end yeah who need
that white bathing suit that she wears
in that scene turkey imported from me
yeah you would also need towels imported
from Turkey of course and we don't have
that in this job yeah no unfortunately
yeah they're a little out of budget but
maybe if this drop is successful we can
afford it yeah so everyone tomorrow shot
more nito's comm check out our Instagram
stories the morning toast for some sneak
peek and we'll keep dropping all day
today pictures of new products on our
Instagram so that when the store
launches you know what to expect but
keep in mind this is the back-to-school
themed drop so you got your sorority
sweatshirts we got your notebooks we got
your folders we got your pens we got
your pencils we got your pencil cases
we've got your koozies because you know
you got a tailgate but you're back at
school we got our what do they call
those what about us well so you
but it's not smoke that's well it's well
but it's it's a it's a water bottle it's
12 so we can keep the prices down for
you yeah oh so also its factors will
seemed but it's not just her students I
mean look at us it's no you know no
because this is like sorority
it's like varsity letters but it's
magnets for your fridge it's folders for
your business like it's pertinent to
every situation I don't know like I
don't really you know have a real job so
I don't know if I need a folder but like
I've got it get some paperwork because I
got to fill my folders up there might
have a product I actually have a lot of
stray things like papers in my bag and I
need a folder for my purse like just to
keep everything you know so it doesn't
get all crumpled so make sure you check
that out shop morning toast calm
tomorrow well there's coming a set of
three and each one secure than the next
we are also going to be recapping Real
Housewives of Dallas later in this
ominous episode Andy NOC and tomorrow
Cameron Westcott joins us from the Real
Housewives of Dallas which will be a
jolly good time it's also a camera on
camera and Wescott friendly drop very
much so the modern-day sharp a truly
sharp a grew up to be captain sharp a
walked so Cameron West could run totally
um also just another housekeeping
announcement if you had tickets to my
Chicago show this weekend please check
your email they have been postponed till
December for very good reason I just
want to make sure everyone gets you know
no one that shows up this weekend yeah
that's important check your email if
it's not there check your junk file and
promotions folder and spam and spam and
your snatchler I'm like an IT guy now
you know totally sure for sure sure
Margot is so patronizing like I mean she
keeps us in check she's little sis you
know what's good counts not much just
how's your air conditioning situation I
watched your stories out sound can you
give me some background yeah basically
me and my romaine are both dealing with
this issue of our eras on both like it
colds but we are waking up stripping and
sweat but freezing like literally like
it's the weirdo you problem no but what
was happening to her - man you both are
sick because you all you do is hang out
with each other no everyone responds to
my story saying like oh my god this is
happening to me too okay this is an
issue I can't speak for Nicole but I
think for you it's like you're dreaming
of the campers and they're just there
you're breaking a sweat
yeah like cold sweats or night sweats I
don't know what it is but so last night
we did it experiment and Nicole slept
with no a/c on and
said it was so much better and she
didn't sweat so now I don't know it's
you yeah but because it happens to me
like 50 degrees in New York today and
the outside weather definitely and when
you have so many windows in your
apartment affects the inside weather so
she probably slept good because it was
rainy the Sun wasn't out and there was
no heat going into the apartment from
outside right but why am i sweating when
it's freezing in my room I don't know
that sounds like a medical condition on
you yeah people told me I had
tuberculosis it's possible I think I
went that and that my apartment was
haunted or yellow fever tuberculosis
that's what I think that's what it is
yeah it's definitely summer qo says well
we would shoot the best of luck in your
journey too honestly problems with air
conditioning are like the worst types of
problems it's not even my air
conditioning is fabulous so you say you
are fabulous like makes it my it click a
word that like Ramona Singer uses yes
yeah this house is fabulous and the
snatch alert what is it Margaux fabulous
I love you it's so cute
every time you say that it's like I want
to cry I'm so sad when we were at
reunion Katie kept saying everything was
fabulous and like every time she said I
was like what an interesting word choice
this is fabulous
yeah I mean for coming from her like it
worked but it's just an interesting word
choice and so now hearing the snatch
like I'm very fabulous sensitive not
everyone can pull off calling things
fabulous in a very specific adjectives
it's just Ramona Singer Katie gross
Margot soiree okay this is just not
sorry everybody
we are you think it's time in the words
of my favorite actress from the Lion
King commercial and broad right on the
cabs we just started
Wow okay it's time to deliver the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's time but
I want to talk about something Margaret
I spoke about last week about how we
think we're gonna start going to therapy
because like it just sounds like a
really fun excuse to start talking about
ourselves obviously um we made no
progress because like life is busy and
you can't always just like get to the
Upper West Side for therapist meeting
and they're all therapists are by the
way 1,000% it's like what do you think I
have all the time in the j-2x up to
crotch town that's my talk space is
everything you need if you're thinking
about go to therapy we all need someone
to talk to you a person who can support
us through rough patches or even the
everyday ups and downs of life and
that's where talk space comes in it's
therapy for how we live today it's
mobile available when you need it and
it's affordable life can be stressful
between work family and everything in
between
not always easy to find some time for
yourself talk space online therapy makes
taking care of your mental health more
affordable and convenient than ever
before simply provide your preferences
for therapy and talk space will match
with you match you with one of the five
thousand-plus therapists the very same
day send your therapist unlimited text
audio picture and video messages from
anywhere at any time no matter what
you're going through you're not alone
join more than a million a million
people who feel happier with talk space
fighting the right therapist doesn't
have to be stressful the top space
matching process takes your unique
preferences into account - finding
someone whose style and experience
matches your needs and if you want to
switch therapists you can do so at any
time at no extra cost it's affordable
one month of therapy on the top space
platform costs about the same amount as
a single face-to-face session best of
all you'll never have to wait a week to
share what's on your mind they have more
than 5,000 licensed therapists who are
experienced in addressing their
challenges we all face to match with
your perfect therapist for a fraction of
the price of traditional therapy go to
talk space.com make sure to use the code
toast to get sixty five dollars off your
first month and show your support for
our show that's toast at talk space.com
and i'm going to do this and I will
report back a precious wonderful thing I
have to and if you're one of the things
about therapy in general but I don't
know how people like have the time to
like get to and from therapy and like
also have jobs and Families yeah yeah
this helps it's quite puzzling ya know
this is this is it this is the future
yeah okay well without further ado I
want to get into the first story because
it's shaking me to my core Kylie Jenner
reunites with Tyga during girls night
amid her break with Travis Scott you
guys I saw this story and I was like
that is not Kylie that is a Philae I
refuse to believe it but it's everywhere
it's one of those Instagram models who
looks just like Kylie but double like it
is known that it's hurt you no one's
questioning it I know this is what he
news has to say and when it comes to the
Kardashians like I'm gonna take it for
me news yeah I guess Kylie Jenner is
seeking comfort from her friends
including ex Tyga after her recent split
from Travis Scott but as salacious as
this might sound the truth is far from
it a source tells enums that the former
couple met up late Tuesday night after
Kylie and her friends Stasi and Kelsey
enjoyed a late-night bite at Hollywood
hotspot Delilah cool Kylie wanted to
have a girls night out last night and
Stasi thought it would be best to get
her out of the house and her mind off
the news he was with a few of their
mutual friends at Sunset Marquis and
invited Kylie and her girlfriends to
come hang out since they were already
out
the insider does add that Kylie and Tyga
quote have been in touch since their
split in 2017 but that they don't talk
often
moreover the source explained says this
wasn't a slide towards Travis who she
parents Trotters stormy Webster with nor
does it mean that their breakup is
permanent the insider says it wasn't an
intentional jab at Travis but she did
hang out with tyga for a bit nothing
romantic is going on okay well then that
makes me feel better because to be
honest that would be such a step down
like I think tyga it's the worst thing
that ever happened to Kylie no I think
it was it was good at that time but like
she is just in a different stratosphere
now and on the one hand I'm like you
can't be friends with an ex you can't
and they were like married yeah they
work hard living to get like they were
attached at the hip so I don't think
it'll go from that to just being friends
but then I look at like Khloe and French
Montana and how a lot of the girls and
their exes like because you were a
trustworthy friend of the family you
will always be in the circle therefore
it's safe to hang out with you French
Montana is very interesting because I
think he is probably one of the only
ones who is I don't know what happened
in this time with Khloe but he did
something to make a lasting impression
on the family that they could always
trust him and he will always be there
for her for them and like something he
did or something he said really impacted
Kris Jenner in a way where like he's now
allowed every family function even
though it's he's like an awkward ex of
Khloe even though I kind of feel like
him and Khloe like could end up together
like they are OTP like I think they were
actually really good for each other
maybe he was like not the right time and
like they were doing their Hampton show
and like he was like DJing in Atlantic
City and yes like that is so far to
travel she was taking like car services
from the Hamptons to Atlantic City it's
it's ours are you the walkers in the car
I did it once torture of course they
couldn't make it work
I'll do anything for a party even drive
six hours we're going from Atlantic City
to the Hamptons Ferb it was I don't know
looking we had had the weekend in
Atlantic City but it was a big party on
Sunday so like but me but I wanted to go
we literally drove like you have to
drive you go back to the city and then
back to the Hamptons it's literally the
most torturous Drive I can't believe or
maybe for a wedding maybe I don't know
but we did it
that's crazy she was doing it all the
time while filming the show like they
never stood a chance but now it's like
they each they have they run in the same
circle obviously like they have the same
priorities I don't know I could see it
and it's now that for now that
Courtney's
shacked up with Brad because that blind
was revealed it's time for Khloe to find
some love but you know what like I think
you would have thought you would have
thought that once they broke up like
they were really because they were in
such different places in their lives
like they never would have seen each
other again but because the fact that
like they literally see each other once
a week it makes more sense like the
universe is really trying to bring them
together yeah and I hope I think he
would be a good father like he is like
good family values I get the vibe like
he's religious like I think there's good
stuff there I think there's good stuff
there too maybe he had something growing
up to do yeah and he was like a rapper
he just popped on the scene you just
want to like get [ __ ] like oh yes yeah
and now he's been on the scene for a
while and then once you're on the scene
you realize the scenes like not that
great even look he got the [ __ ] I'm
like it was nothing like Khloe
Kardashian's nothing she has nothing
like used Joseph's cookie she has said
herself that she has a pet [ __ ] yeah
PHH a nice very nice nothing like those
jars of cookies on her on her table like
are you gonna get that we're gonna get
that anywhere also can we like could we
die from how many times the word [ __ ]
was said on Real Housewives of Dallas I
know that we've spoken about this before
but the P word [ __ ] like I don't know
when we were growing up like I like we
were I were actually remember we used to
say that's how we described our visions
like [ __ ] and then we were told he was
like a pornographic porn yeah and then I
was like okay now it's the P word and
you hear it on TV it's just like it
should are any icy [ __ ] with two
completely different I know what you're
gonna say I see like disgusting like
like discussing and then it also see
like a young child's like vagina like
when you're a baby like oh go wash your
[ __ ] like yeah like yeah it's like a
maternal yeah it's a childish way of
like a vagina is very and it's all
illogical yes it's like this is the
vaginal organ yeah but he's like a sweet
way of saying it it's dirty way a snatch
oh that's true yeah there's so many
different like idioms for it but I think
that it's actually shocking how [ __ ]
has to completely start and it's like if
someone's mom was like rush oppose
anything of it but then like when Brandi
Redmond is like who has a hairier [ __ ]
like it's like a truck stop like it's
disgusting
yeah it's crazy how it has dual meaning
it is crazy and then I wonder if just us
associate like the innocent meaning like
to other people have that innocent
meeting oh because we all raised calling
it that way yeah I'm sure they do but
I'd be interested to know everyone's
[ __ ] experience the one about the [ __ ]
that's a record show totally we're gonna
be competing with collar daddy
oh my god for sure their titles like I'm
like click click yeah I actually need to
run reports to see if how our titles are
affecting our viewership yeah because I
think it would make it more interesting
than to just click Wednesday October
yeah second it was a branding decision
yeah but we also need to see if you know
our analysis fared fruit it's the
scientific method did I hypothesis based
on the comments on YouTube people are
disagreeing like they didn't have the
experience of growing up we're using the
P word it's like a sweet endearing term
I haven't never referred to a child's
vagina as a [ __ ] okay that's so crazy
because my mom has never asked me this
is where like podcasting becomes so
interesting podcasting with your family
because like you and I have the pretty
much the same life experience I guess
you went to college upstate but that's
like the craziest thing you ever did and
it's just so shocking to like reach so
many different people with your podcast
like had totally different life
experiences in you and we raised so
differently and like just things that
you think are facts like are not you
know and like that's like we used to
think the like tylenol was like the
devil's juice yeah you feel like like
Tylenol was so bad for you just cuz we
were like an advil household I think the
Tylenol does do something to your liver
that advil does imput Advil also does
things a tylenol doesn't like I've over
you if you've a semuc it like do that
yeah um anyways it is interesante back
to Kylie and Tyga I'm not here for it
I'm not here for it and I also don't
believe it like I don't think she would
take all these steps forward just to go
back to Tyga you know yeah do you think
it's having a snatcher yeah it's
fabulous
do you know fabulous Posey yeah she's
gonna stab you with snatch mr.
world-renowned she has to in order to
remain on brand I'm speaking of the
snatcher it's something I've been
putting pressure on Margo to do that I
want to now put like public pressure I
know you're gonna say
I really I know that the bachelors on
hiatus and there's not enough content to
do a show about The Bachelor but I
really want you to continue the snatcher
as like your personal podcast where you
like to talk about your life and you
have your friends on and you just talk
about like being young and fabulous
would you guys would your friends but I
feel like people would actually like cuz
like to me you're like the coolest
person I know like you're fabulous
you're New York's usually graduated New
York like you're snatch to the gods you
have tons of friends like to me like
that's an interesting like Gossip Girl
podcast yeah yeah it's not my call so if
any of us yeah so you agree you think
you really yes okay like let's see what
other people think cuz if people are
like oh yeah nod your head on with you
because like we're like grandmas we
can't get out I want this podcast so I
can listen to it so I can know what's
going on with you but like what a
different like person every week like
friends you know fellow Instagram bikini
girls know what about that beautiful
girl who we met at the spotify event
who's a toaster oh my guys totally yeah
you should podcast for their yeah no
Instagram bikini girls okay okay
I'll work on okay cool thank you okay
I'm glad and I think I Bromley
appreciate it
anyways um Kylie we're with you what
every but ultimately whatever she
decides to do is what's best I guess but
Tigers not exist no I know but say she
goes back with him fine it's just must
be nice to be able to do whatever you
want like you don't need a man for
anything other than companionship like I
feel like there's so many politics when
it comes to relationships like when
you're not a billionaire and like you
you don't have kids like you have to
think about all this stuff but she got
her kid shot a billion dollars now it's
like who am I gotta [ __ ] tonight and
that's nice yeah but then you also I
think billionaires having the problem
where it's like are people using me for
my billions well you can't let them and
Kylie I feel like in the Jordan woods
cynic situation really learned a lot
about letting people mooch off of her
and that's what she said in the
Kardashians episode she said we need to
check our like Jordan was literally
living in my house like we needed to
grow a K she needs to stop mooching off
of me so that she learned a valuable
lesson there totally okay next up Lisa
Vanderpump's shade Sarah Paulson after
actress said she wasn't that nice Lisa
said not sure I know her
when Real Housewives superfan Sarah
Paulson claimed to Vanity Fair that upon
the meeting Lisa Vanderpump briefly at a
party the restauranteur quote wasn't
that nice to her the American Horror
Story star added that she didn't want
her coming after me on Twitter so there
a game on some Vanity Fair video and
they put a picture of Lisa Vanderpump
and they were like will you miss Lisa
Vanderpump and she was like no but I'll
miss like the fear she and the fear of
God that she instills a never cast
member because that's an interesting
dynamic and then she was like I don't
know if I should say this bug I met her
at a party like she was that nice to me
I don't want her coming from me on
Twitter and then and then Lisa came to
Twitter and said I'm sorry not sure I
know her and I don't believe or remember
meeting her I don't believe what like
she would make this up you know
she's a like a world-renowned superstar
she's talking about you right I am I
believe that Lisa Vanderpump didn't know
who she is I don't know if like she
spends her time watching American
country or she's like she's British
she's older like she's in a different
demographic of the people that watch my
can heart story and I actually do firmly
believe that she had no idea who Sarah
Paulsen was when she met her I'm further
proving that Lisa Vanderpump was just an
[ __ ] to people unless she knows who
you are right unless you're Lady Gaga
Miley Cyrus Selena Gomez going to TomTom
yeah that's like the worst type of
person to be like to be called out like
for being rude to someone cuz you didn't
know who they were and then they
actually turn out to be like very nice
or very important like a very famous
yeah that's been you know your true
piece of [ __ ] Lisa Vanderpump for sure
but sometimes and I feel like now that
I've seen this like even with us where
people have like said like I was rude to
them or something and I'm like I'm
thinking of that time at that concert
and it's like no you're reading the
whole situation completely wrong yeah no
totally
you were being inappropriate I think
there's a difference in like a fan
claiming that Lisa Vanderpump was rude
to them and Sarah Paulsen clearly well
what's the alson have to be said and I
don't think it's anything to gain but
still Lisa Vanderpump should treat
everyone just kind of like 1000 you're
saying no that's the problem here right
is that she 100% didn't know who Sarah
Paulsen was thought she was like you
know from Middle America came to Sur to
see Lisa Vanderpump and Lisa Vanderpump
treated her like she treats everyone
else like the [ __ ] beneath her shoe and
it turns out that she's actually a
superstar
yeah joke's on you joke's on you sheep
literally think she's Mariah Carey I
don't know her yeah that's exactly what
it is yeah no I just really am here for
like the downfall of Lisa Vanderpump
also is the sunny news no there's some
people okay so I read this article one
of my new favorite sources they just
really yeah I feel like they're straight
to the chase they don't editorialize and
you know we haven't experienced them
writing fake things about us so I can
trust them I'm sorry we have breaking
news yeah
Kylie Jenner tweeted about Tyga oh my
god the image matching the toast the
internet makes everything a hundred
times more dramatic than what it really
is
there was no 2:00 a.m. date with Tyga
you see me drop two friends off at a
studio that he happened to be at Travis
and I are on great terms and our main
focus right now with stormy our
friendship and daughter is our priority
that's obviously confirming that her and
Travis are not together but her and Tyga
are definitely not either like this is
not a thing this is just like he was in
the right place right time okay well
maybe post us to the toast Instagram cuz
like you know we're come stay on the
forefront of breaking news we are so
he's Margo Jackie talk amongst ourselves
I know it's actually I just knew it you
just knew it I mean I'm glad to see her
taking to Twitter just like nip things
no statements I'm sure she was like I'll
wait to see what the morning toast says
because they know me best unless they're
not gonna say we were together and then
we said they were together and she was
like [ __ ] I got it I got a clear he's
got a toast thing so yeah I got a
cleared up and I'm grateful I love when
somebody's just like take to Twitter
like a couple publications have it that
was like when Raylan gates posted that
screenshot of an email she got from like
In Touch magazine me like we have a
doctor who said you got her titties done
is it true we're running it if you don't
answer us in an hour she's like she just
posted a screenshot yeah I got her to
the Sun five years ago yeah and they
look great okay it's posted so back to
its regular scheduled programming
awesome okay third story isn't update
from a crazy story from last week that
has swept the nation swept the toast of
Earth and I want to give everyone the
update because the Ukrainian orphan
accused of being an adult was found
living with another family in Indiana
Natalya the orphan at the center of the
adoption scandal has been the subject of
shocking allegations and multiple
questions about her age I know there's
like a lot of questions about her age
but I feel like if her name is Natalia
she has to be 30 yeah there was no
six-year-old named Natalia no no perhaps
Natalia who was born in the Ukraine was
left in Indiana in 2013 when her
adoptive family moved to Canada the
family has since allege that not only
was she terrifying and dangerous but
that she was actually in her 20s as
charges against her adoptive parents
make their way to court Natalya has
reportedly been living with another
family in Indiana so amid the
controversy missed accounts surrounding
Natalya the Ukrainian orphan at the
center of the adoption scandal has
reportedly been living with a Christian
family in the same state where she was
left by a family moved to Canada and
she's
literally conning another family wait
like this story is so crazy and can very
easily be put to rest with just a simple
visit to the doctor's office to see how
old this [ __ ] is a simple visit to the
dentist is this yeah is this a case of
you know conning or a crime of a badge
of child neglect
yeah or child fraud fraud or adult fraud
Yeah right right right right right
it's just like it's so silly like the
story is going on for so long when the
answer is I feel really clear like just
find out how old she is yeah and you
could tell how old a body is based on
teeth badum based on bone density like
there's a million things yeah I just
don't think that they can get their
hands on the girl right yeah she's a
little scoundrel
yes she's she's adult camper she's a
menace just running around the country
to get damaged man of Christian families
no totally is she just a child looking
for a loving home right like or is she
like the biggest victim ever right I
don't know a child with a full bush oh
yeah forget the blood should I forget
the bush wait what's the bush remember
that's why your mom actually thought she
was older than two guys she had a period
and a bush oh yeah yeah yeah luckily I'm
Lankan exactly
she had a cheetah everybody say yeah
that's a discussing me to talk about a
child I'm really sorry
or net worth adult I know I'm clear I'm
just not trying to be like a like a
predator out here I understand well I
hope that this next family can just turn
her in just for like a NHS yeah I'd like
to see her the doctor and like secretly
be like hey how old is this [ __ ] yeah I
don't know it's taken for a checkup and
then be like we run some tests yeah it's
so weird it's like what is the best way
to determine someone's age seat anything
yeah you just got to snag one but does
she have baby teeth oh right but I don't
think you have baby teeth when you're
eight you don't know I think you know
they're all now actually they're in the
midst like when I was eight I get up see
one of her two front teeth she's
probably digging out her teeth like just
nobody has teeth attract she has teeth
in this picture I'm a poor couple on the
left yeah nice yeah and I just I I don't
know it's it's confusing cuz anyone who
would like adopt a child like bring them
into their home and at the goodness of
their heart
how can they be us in the name of Christ
right how can they also be child abandon
earth I don't think so I think this kid
is demonic that's if I'm not a betting
woman but if I was it would be on the UH
that she's an adult yeah okay fair well
next story a little uh business but it's
an interesting factoid because ATM fees
have set a record high of course
approaching five dollars and now cost an
average four dollars and seventy two
cents to take money out of an ATM that
isn't owned by your bank the highest
amount since bakery calm started
tracking the data in 1998 like this is
like that's insane I went to the bay
cast I went to the knock Bank yesterday
at CVS it was just closer and I use
three dollars and it's just like you
know what eight dollars is worth the
five blocks but still it's not worth the
five blocks also this is so tragic it's
for people in New York who are not Chase
Bank members like if you're a Chase Bank
remember you can pretty much avoid an
ATM fee 100% of the time like there is I
live between three chase banks in a
three-block rating not all of us are as
lucky I'm just saying like there's a
chase literally on every corner of the
city and the only problem I ever the
only time I ever have this problem is
when I'm in the casino and it is not
five dollars it's more like a casino
because they know you're like thirsting
and drunk and also that's the above app
like it averages out at four right
dollars and four dollars and seventy two
cents
that is so crazy ATM fees are the
biggest load of [ __ ] ever like shame
on them that is corporate greed at its
finest right like I'm just try and get
my hard-earned money and your pay making
me pay to take my own money
I literally won't do it like I know I
won't do it either
and that's why it's so annoying in a
nail salon when they don't let you tip
on the card pic oh but we have an ATM
and they think you're helping you but
like say no I got to pay three dollars
to get my 20 bucks yeah but then they
take off the tax it's just but they're
also dealing with the ATM fees too they
don't get the fee no but also so income
who'd have you seen nail salons that
like is like if you spend a certain
amount of money then they waive the ATM
fee so it's a it can be a well so I
think the ATM fee is split between the
bandar
hold on me I have it the total doesn't
just go to that out-of-network Bank it
goes toward the customers own Bank for
using an out-of-network machine oh so
easy chase is making money off of you
using an on chase mm-hmm machine but
what's the bank where if you achieve
Liebig you get all those fees back so TD
Bank if you subscribe
bank accounts and one of their premier
bank accounts it's like it's a few more
dollars a month they refund at the end
of every month every ATM fee that you
that you charge which is actually really
enticing but not enticing enough for me
to move right Love Canal so you're
paying for that it all right it all
comes out wash yeah this is just a
[ __ ] like [ __ ] ATM fees are just
so hypocritical
yeah that's why people keep money on to
their mattress I hear ya also cash back
at the grocery store so underrated I've
never done it except when we were in
camp like you always needed cash and
there was no banks at camps like we went
to CVS like you want $10 back on Mike
actually I do
yeah I didn't like cash back that's
actually a great call they charge you
for cash backing out and but I feel like
with these new demonic checkout machines
that some people are just going into
fits of rage over I don't think that you
can do cash bags in a self checkout I've
seen the option but I've never explored
it so I'm like how does that even work
I think they literally need to get like
a an associate bringing the whole point
as well go to the checkout right but I'm
all about cashback man maybe one of
those Capital One commercials I just
thought this is something that like this
is insane and people need to know about
it yeah and I thought it was just high
in certain parts of the country but I
guess it's high everywhere yeah well
it's higher in like casinos uh-huh but
the average is for is almost $5 it's
like that's so crazy insane it's insane
okay there then find a story a little
vaping news because we here at the
morning toast care about your health and
we haven't spoke about vaping in a while
but now researchers are saying that
they're looking into these lung
illnesses that vaping is causing and
despite the recent surge in vaping
related illnesses
doctors suspect they've seen such cases
in the past it looks like the kind of
injury on the lungs that we normally see
when a person is exposed to a spilled
drum of toxic chemicals at their
workplace so they're looking like
asbestos like toxic
chemical burns may be behind the
hundreds of vaping linked to illnesses
spiking across the country according to
new images of lung tissue taken from
people who got sick after vaping the
images and resulting analysis for
pathologists were published Wednesday in
the New England Journal of Medicine the
findings provide a better understanding
of what's actually happening to the
lungs in these cases they're also meant
to give doctors other doctors a frame of
reference for what the vaping related
injuries look like under a microscope as
well as help in diagnosis so confusing
they still haven't gotten to the bottom
and by the way I have stopped rolling I
have not jeweled since Austin because
everyone was telling me that you know
it's gonna kill me but I it's to feel
any better um no I feel the same but
also the research like is not conclusive
and like at a certain point if they
can't tell me for real like what vaping
is doing I'm gonna go back today because
I've actually been reading up a lot on
it ever since I quit because I really
want to know no one knows no the point
is that no one knows all of this is just
like nervous accusations and there are
people who say that vaping is fine for
you and then there are people saying no
it's gonna kill you and it's it's um
there's not it's not it's the case isn't
settled yet oh so it's going to be that
part of a like THC no this is jewel this
is overall it's just I feel like it
shouldn't be that hard like they have a
hundred cases like figure it out yeah is
it like I just feel like it's not that
crazy I don't know but maybe I don't
want to be a conspiracy theorist but
like maybe it's just not that crazy like
maybe like Big Tobacco is behind this
because they want everyone to go back to
smoking cigarettes so they can put
vaping out of business look I realize
it's hypocritical of me to say because I
love a jewel but like I think swimming
cigarette something like notice smells
so much work this is not-- I don't care
like I'm sure my social ramifications
like I think it's so disgusting like it
smells so bad like your tan smell your
teeth smell then you like try and cover
it up with gum and then this smell of
like gum mixed with smoke it's like I
just say it just got saying no and not
to be like judgmental because like I'm
discussing piece of trash who loves a
jewel but I just think that smoking
cigarettes is by oh yeah to each their
own someone asked me why I would go back
if I stopped because I liked it it was
fun
yeah and I also haven't been like out on
the town since Austin but it was really
helping me drink significantly less so I
don't know I don't know it's like damned
if you do damned if you're don't damn
speaking of Jules we have a new jewel
skin on our store tomorrow and it is so
cute it matches our air pods but that's
what's quo we have an air pod skin so
you can keep your same air pod case and
this is a decal that wraps not only the
case of the air pods but the two pods -
I'm really excited about it I know you
did can you do for me I was about to say
I want to like hire a professional
because I definitely can I was really
nervous but this stickiness like it
makes it so that even if you make a
mistake you can pull it over to the
steel sticky but not too sticky where
you can't pull it off anyways that's the
baking news of the day and just want to
keep you guys updated because we are
we've been talking about Jules you've
seen us Julie let's be responsible if
we're gonna continue to sell drill
skills but again only buy a jewel skin
if you already are drilling we do not
endorse drooling it is bad for you
nicotine is bad for you now 18 is an
addictive chemical it's an addictive
chemical if it helps you great buy a
sticker but if it doesn't stay away from
the jewel we are not endorsing or in any
way promoting unhealthy habits hmm
long-term consequences I'm just going
down to at the bottom of the article
most patients with vaping related
injuries are able to recover with
steroids and or a supplemental oxygen
but some have succumb to the illnesses
hmm okay so still it's it but right no
one will tell you I missed it it's
basically it's still inconclusive was
that good story that it was that this
story it's better to be safe than sorry
but you gotta live your life's about the
Fitz story that was the fit story okay
we're gonna do a Real Housewives of
Orange County and Dallas recap because
they were both really actually very
premium episodes let's you Orange County
first we ended the trip in Miraval Kelly
and Vicki had like a really emotional
reunion at that dinner Jeana was just
being her annoying self and award for
biggest weenie of the night goes to
Emily oh my god I had to call Claudia
because I was so in shock when Emily was
like cozying up to Tamra it was so like
over-the-top and insincere no not even
that it was so lame and it was so cringy
and I'm like Emily and like I really
want her to win and I feel bad for her
because I think she feels so
uncomfortable in her own skin especially
in this group
she like doesn't know her place and she
had like one good thing going with Jeana
and like now it's been kerfuffled and so
I doubt what she was trying to do but
like be cool like come on don't be all
uncool do not be in that she was being
the definition of uncool yeah I I don't
know the thing between Vicki and Kelly I
was really glad that they were able to
you know see each other but I totally
understand where Kelly was kind of like
this and this happens all the time on
these shows where these women go after
each other in a way that like could
defamatory damaging and can ruin their
lives and at what point you say like I
do not want to be around I will not even
look at this person and it's really like
Tamra and Shannon yes to pick sides
I agree no I totally get why Kelly is so
upset at Tamra and Shannon especially
given the fact that Vicki is not even a
housewife anymore there's no reason for
her to have been on this trip other than
the fact that she was invited by them
and then Kelly gets his reputation for
being like so crazy but it's like she's
saying such evil things about Kelly like
of course she's gonna what she has a
drink like go insane I totally felt
Kelly and I and I I got exactly what she
was saying and I was actually very
grateful that she said I'm sorry I
called you a pig look I know it's it
just it's the one thing I can say that
hurts you because Slade called you that
and that was like an actually really
like honest thing for her to say because
Vicki's coming out her with all these
terrible defamatory like drugs sex
school with her kids
except like what can she say to fight
back and I guess this is the only thing
she can say and I didn't I wasn't even
mad at her for it because I know you
should never talk about someone else's
appearance but like come on yeah but you
also shouldn't say things about your
friends that can land them in jail so
yeah the rule book is kind of out the
window here yeah I was really um I was
happy in that moment but I biggie is not
to be trusted
no and this happens with every single
friend she's ever had like she goes for
the jugular each time and they always
like Tamra always lets her back in
because of the show but it's like now
you don't have to she's not even a
housewife anymore
yeah hey I understand Kelly's
frustration with Tamra especially now
watching back how Tamra Tamra brought up
the train again yes episode yeah no I I
totally I get it um the episode probably
took me like over two hours to get
through between life just being
distracted but I guess it was a good
episode I'm glad they wound up having
fun Miraval looks really nice like
I just that last night like I feel like
when the housewives of oh so you feel
like they're having a bad season like
they just go swimming naked and like it
they think it's gonna make it all better
yeah but they also all have rockin bod
so like I Bronwyn and her threesomes oh
yeah that was weird
um yeah it was crazy when she brought it
up and you could see like she didn't
want to say but you also kind of wanted
to say like hey guys like I'm there's
more to me than meets the eye but so
like then wanted to stop tossed out of
it like that's not how it works
um but it definitely it definitely
shakes things up and she there is more
to her than meets the eye yeah but it's
like she has such a crazy light like she
has seven children how do they have time
to literally find a third person no but
do what you gotta do girl in order to
you know make it all work you know yeah
there's no formula I really go back and
forth between Bronwyn but think between
thing and she's like fine and harmless
and just then also thinking she's like
so like I'm necessary yeah I
I'll give her time because everyone does
any time and she came in so hot that we
all just like glazed over anything she
might have done wrong in the person who
episodes because we all liked her so
much so now I need to figure out where I
stand with her you know see what happens
when they get back to the OC um I need
to talk about Real Housewives of Dallas
because I didn't realize like what this
franchise was missing until last night
and what it's been missing this whole
time is a genuine friendship between
Cameron and Randy it is the best thing
ever I really like loved Cameron laughs
I've been loving her but when she said
when Kerri said to her like you're so
fun and then seven she's and then
something he was like you're so fun and
then when Cameron said to her like it
was annoying that she had to ruin the
moment looking for a fight no and that
was annoying but what she said writing
so true it was like I've always been
this fun you guys have never given me a
chance you've just judged me straight
off the bat like you think I'm like
Highland Park stick up my ass snob and
it's true we all did know by the way
it's true but she also is much more
laid-back that like last season she was
Highland Park stick up her ass like she
saw herself on TV in a really humanized
her she is she's much too that she's
much more different she's more laid-back
because she's more comfortable like she
came into the group she only knew the
answer like you're not gonna be open
with everyone right off the bat those
things take time
no now she has friends with the answer
she's friends with Leon she's friends
with new Carrie and so she's more
herself and then everyone else's but
they never
get that they judged her for sure but
she was much more rigid like she was so
like she it was part of them judging her
and also part her just like being
insecure and like being she would stick
up her ass she did but like I think she
never was she still has a stick up her
ass it's much smaller it's smaller but
they never gave her the opportunity to
be herself I know I was right there with
them judging her I was like oh she's and
it was like we were looking for
something were carried uber kept being
like she's so smart she's so smart she's
so smart and it's like I'm looking for
smart and I wasn't seeing it but what we
didn't realize is like she's just a nice
genuine like goodtime girl good friend
and also true to herself in the scenes
from next week is Carrie doober at LuAnn
sting looks like Lee Anne it looks like
it that's weird
yeah the convey never got along ever and
he gets his dick stuck to the roundup
boys who did it yeah they're just hands
the trip like in general looked like
actual torture in terms of all
housewives trips like the the itinerary
was jam-packed with crap like what
couldn't they just literally go to the
beach and lots my heart went out to
Deandra the whole day I would like when
she woke up with that hangover
I don't know like I don't know she
wasn't that your it scares me to think
I'm 26 years old I turned 27 next month
my birthday's coming up which is so
crazy
um and my hangovers are category six I
don't know what that means I think it's
bad I think it's kind of when I turn 50
what's it gonna be yeah they were Jackie
so much everything so like she not only
was so hungover she did everything the
next day she had such a good attitude
you could see she was still hungover and
I was just the whole episode I was
thinking like how is the answer still
alive I know I know I was really in awe
and inspired by her relentless you know
perseverance so it it really scares me
to think about what my hangovers will be
like at 15 yeah I just thought the trip
was like first of all really short like
when they said was the last item on you
just got there yesterday yeah it was
literally out two and a half day trip
that's why I'm assuming they're gonna be
going on another trip this was just oh
and weren't maybe we can go to erm
uptrend yeah and from Dallas to Mexico
it's like it's an easy trip up well it
was supposed to be um I had two problems
last night because I was really warming
up to Cameron and like loving her
friendship with Brandi and my problem
with Kate Brett Cameron has always been
when she does get into arguments like
she is super illogical like she was like
why am i coming here to be attacked when
Brandis like sitting there just telling
her like why what she said triggered her
yeah like I just think she has a hard
time seeing someone else's perspective
but I actually thought it was very cool
of LeAnn to step in earlier in the day
and be like I know why Brandis triggered
by this like you grew up so difference
like you might not be able to understand
like I grew up in the carnival my people
that are used to stare at us like yeah
Cameron could never get in in Brandi's
mindset because you have totally
different life experiences and I thought
it was nice of LeAnn to like chime in in
the beginning who and LeAnn got up and
stopped she had being using the night
before as a frame of reference he had no
one would let me talk to Carrie last
night you all were wasted that was just
an German who wouldn't let you leave
yeah and also it was like a group and
also I think that grandi would have
spoke to Cameron if the whole group was
there it's the difference between three
and it's two on one upgrade Cameron and
leanne versus brandy if the whole group
is there so everyone can hear the
conversation and just so we're all in
the same patient people don't have to
like go back and say what happened and
you know and then it's a game of
telephone like if it's diction they
would have had that conversation in
front of the whole group three people is
like the worst amount of people in a
conversation like it could never have
been Brandi and Stephanie talking to
Cameron right ever and that's the same
thing as Cameron and Liana and so as
much as I love Lee and she was so wrong
it was so wrong last night at every turn
and when she was talking to brandy at
the dinner like getting in her face like
Brittany was really for the first time
left I've seen bready she Brittany goes
wild to like bring it out Liane she was
so common just really like not in the
mood to fight like she was Dutton like
yeah guns weren't down yeah and LAN was
still like pointing in her face and then
all of a sudden she sits down at dinner
and it's like you know I'm really upset
like that this whole trip has been about
someone's 50th birthday when like I'm
getting married soon it was a very Lou
Ann moment yes it's like nobody nobody
nobody Leanne
I'm just really upset like that we're
not here celebrating my wedding right it
was insane it was insane like no that's
not that cause for the trip it's like
D'Andra has no funds carrie was open
nice enough to open up her house and I
think they'll do it back they'll do
something hurt yeah if you're a good
friend to people like they'll treat you
right no that was so strange and it
could love to have all the women
individually were struggling with their
hair in Mexico humidity like D'Andra and
Leanne's hair was just all over the
place oh yeah they're looking more and
more like I know in the view sisters
was in that year like with her big
ponytail I was feeling for her so much I
like her ponytail must be sopping wet
like a mop yeah they've so much hair in
that heat like I don't know how they do
it and they don't put it up never it's
great like Brandis hair was up yeah
Brandi and Stephanie both have looked so
cute oh and then I have to say Cameron
Wescott in a bathing suit it's the only
thing I needed to see former model
supermodel and not even like sometimes
you're so thin that like you're like
body's like a piece of paper it's like
uninteresting like she's curves like
she's a woman's body she was amazing and
honestly so dizzy a dress and what's
great she's always so modest he's
Cameron like if I had that body I would
be what I would be the Real Housewives
of OC being naked in the pool I mean all
day everybody's in a bathing suit she's
in a one-piece yeah and she's always
wearing her cover up like unless she's
going in the water like she's just she's
a supermodel she's a supermodel also
carrie has an amazing body I think she
does Pilates Brandi is that cheerleader
bod like everyone they don't have a mate
and honestly I was so impressed with
Deandra like at age 50 like first of all
she looks so good and like to just get
in your bathing suit on TV is no easy
feat no and I was just I want to say
like I was really proud of her like I
think that was amazing
yeah it was a really good episode
actually I'm like loving Real Housewives
Dallas loving I love the group there's
because there's like real love and real
friendships there and then also like the
dramas interesting too yeah I'm really
looking forward to seeing what happens
between Cameron and Leeanne that causes
them to fight in the next device and
when Cameron joins us tomorrow I have to
ask her if she's her and Brandi or still
friends like I think the show will take
on a life of its own if the two of them
are like besties yeah because like
they're their total opposite dynamics
you would think they're like the least
common people who would ever be friends
they've nothing in common yeah but
there's something there for Sherri I'm
really excited about it I'm here for it
whoo well Wow housewives like literally
gives me like I had a breath no real
houses of Atlanta is back on Sunday Oh
exciting with Kenya
um anymore which I think it's gonna be a
time and don't come for her unless she
told us for you
I'm really excited and Potomac is over
now I think that's it right did you
watch that show it's a man's world or
something no and I've been meaning to
bring it up I watched it
I've been I haven't watched it so I
can't speak on it other than I think
that the idea is so ridiculous and
necessary and what okay so the walk the
first episode ever that aired this week
that I watch she's a professional pool
player like she plays in the Olympics
and she goes to play pool before she
it's like I almost don't want to know
what it's about cuz you'll tell me and
I'll be like oh that's beautiful
no like I mean it is also I thought that
they definitely fudged the results a
little bit because they filmed her
playing and they saw some of the
costumes and like with they filmed her
play pool with male polo players and
they counted how many times she was
insulted during the entire game like you
can't break you [ __ ] ZUP
and then like months later she dresses
in in man clothes and they put on
prosthetics and by the way the day that
she has to do this thing she gets her
period and she's like wearing a full fat
bodysuit like it was the worst day ever
and she goes to like some competition
with the same guys and they actually
played on Amsterdam billiards on eighth
and Broadway you know that place by
where we used to work yeah it looks cool
we should go there and she went in and
like they were like damn you're good
like they didn't even talk to her she
got like 30 compliments and then they
were like she got zero and so it's 30
compliments in the last time she got
thirty insult zero compliments and it
was just like the results we're like a
little too convenient do you know what I
mean let it definitely feel like in
certain industries like if you're a
woman in pool like it's a guy's game I
get it I get it
I just thought it was a kind of extreme
no it's a very extreme show and I
understand the point is like the
treatment of men versus the treatment of
women but like to go to the length of
filming in and putting on prosthetics
like I just think it is like the most
unnecessary show I've ever seen it's at
least an hour to like it was really like
that Hasbro monopoly women's version
like it's like the intention is good but
like yeah I kind of agree why when I saw
the commercial for that show I was like
we've lost it it seems like well this is
also what happens like every time Bravo
releases a new show that's like kind of
crazy I'm like okay they've lost it like
they had their gold in the air it's like
when they came out with below deck I was
like they've lost their guns mad I was
like what the [ __ ] do we care about
people who work on a boat turns out it's
the best show ever on TV so maybe this
will turn into that or maybe now they
finally lost it I don't think end is
involved definitely nice not a lot of
shows that I'm not interested in like a
lot of the home shows Top Chef I don't
I actually probably don't much like 50%
of the content on Bravo but I'm never
like what I'm God's green dilly dally or
this this yeah I understand but we'll
see how it plays out I'm so tired
I think is that it yes so remember merch
is tomorrow Friday we did it on purpose
paid a camera and Wescott toys tomorrow
and then the second the podcast is over
we are going to be opening up our merch
store limited quantities but generous
quantity so everyone should be able to
get what they want but still make sure
to be on super really you have something
in mind like Chinese Indian reminder I
ordered everything that I all the
apparel that I got is a size large and
it fits me very well I don't like
anything too tight so it's like not
baggy but it's loose-fitting but for
these sorority sweatshirts I would
suggest
I'm gonna order another one in the size
extra large you're wearing a lot I'm
going large I got all my morning to
sweatshirts in a size large so I can
wear them as a dress size up one or two
sizes if you wanted to wear it as a
dress with boots are on the ground they
style um for t-shirts
I have mediums but I would if I was
ordering again I would get small so they
could be like more for like t-shirt and
jeans more fitted because the mediums
are just a little shoe long I mean but
they don't cover my butt enough to be a
dress I understand that's where I'm at
um we love you guys think it's so much
listening to the morning toast
millennial Morning Show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so please like this
video thumbs up subscribe turn those
notifications on we're also available as
a podcast anywhere podcast can be found
set Spotify iTunes stitcher IR radio
Public Radio every app you can dream of
cast box even so head over there
subscribe Lea five stars we love you
have a great day we will see you
tomorrow on Friday
you